hi
everyone thanks for that introduction
alex
um hopefully you've all started to wake
up i'm
still two hours earlier so i will be
double fisting my coffee
during this talk um my name is jenny
finkel
i'm an engineer at prismatic and i am
excited to have this opportunity to
share with you
how we use machine learning and natural
language processing
as the backbone of how we do relevance
so given the current audience it's
probably worth mentioning that at
prismatic we're a functional programming
shop
the entire backend is written in closure
the web front end is entirely closure
script
my personal background is academic i
went to graduate school in computer
science focusing on
machine learning and natural language
processing and so doing real artificial
intelligence work in a lisp
makes me feel pretty cool we're also
very involved in the open source
community
you may have caught my colleague jason
wolf's talk on graph here last year
or his on session on schema last night
this talk however is not going to be
about any of that
so i should probably start out by
explaining what we do at prismatic
we work on what we like to call the
discovery problem and so the problem is
this
you're a person you like surfing the web
you like finding stuff to read
and the web is vast so it's not that
hard to find some content you like
in my case that probably means cat
pictures it's probably going to be mixed
in with stuff you don't really like
in my case that would be sports articles
but the problem
is that there's loads and loads more
content out there that you don't see
much of which you would you would
probably really enjoy and this slide is
actually misleading because it makes it
look like you see about as much good
stuff as you miss
when in reality you're going to miss out
on far more than you actually see
and so at prismatic we try to go outside
of your regular sources to bring you
lots more content that we think you'll
like
but which you otherwise would have
missed out on
the virtue of what we do is not taking
your twitter feed or your facebook feed
and reordering the stories in it rather
the virtue is in finding you great stuff
you would have otherwise missed out on
because it's shared by people who are
too far away from you socially
or it's outside of your regular news
sources or it's on the periphery of your
interests
to us this is what serendipity is all
about finding you these gems
a bit more concretely we provide a
personalized news reader
this is the web app up here and so when
we use the term news
we really mean it quite broadly to us it
means anything that people are sharing
or talking about on the web
and so up on this slide is a slice of my
personal home feed
showing a variety of my interests like
cats marijuana reform
functional programming ice cream in san
francisco and burning man
as well as who in my network is
recommending the story
so how do we do this we start off by
crawling the social and the open web
for engaging content that's being shared
we then analyze and categorize all of
the content that we've crawled
and a bit later in the talk i will go
into a bit more detail
about what this analysis looks like and
we then serve up the personalized feeds
that i just showed you for each of our
users
based on their network and their social
and their interests
so in order to build that really good
home feed for me
this is the goal that we must achieve we
want to build a ranker to find a small
number of great articles for a user from
a large document index
so as you already know from the title of
this talk we use machine learning to
solve this problem
i've personally been doing machine
learning for over a decade now
and i've noticed that when people
discuss machine learning artificial
intelligence
especially to people outside the field
and especially especially in the context
of a business
people are attracted to the idea of a
special sauce or secret sauce
and so in this talk i hope to convince
you that there is no secret sauce
but rather much like with cooking is
about paying attention to detail
and making a whole lot of correct
choices in fact
i think this quote by my friend and boss
arya sums it up perfectly
people who use the term secret sauce
know about neither food nor technology
if you think about it it's true
delicious food does not come from a
secret sauce
but rather from fresh high quality
ingredients often simply but properly
prepared
and for each ingredient a good cook will
understand its strengths and its
weaknesses
how it pairs with the other foods in the
dish and how best to prepare it
similarly with machine learning you need
to get all of the details right
and the different components of the
system have to be assembled together
thoughtfully
so on that note here's an outline of the
rest of the talk so that you know what's
in store
so first i'm going to talk about the
data that we have to work with regarding
both our users
and our index of documents then i'll
discuss
some of the constraints that we needed
to work within
after that i'll cover evaluation how do
we even know if we did a good job
at this point we'll have built up enough
information that i can actually explain
to you how our system works
after that is my favorite part of the
talk all of the problems that we
encountered along the way
putting a machine learning system into
production was definitely a learning
experience
since my previous experience had all
been academic um
then i'll tell you how our final trained
ranker actually performed on real users
and then there should be some time at
the end for questions
so let's get started with what data we
have to work with
we have a lot of documents we don't have
google scale documents
because our goal isn't to operate over
every page on the web
instead we want recent documents of a
more timely nature
like i said earlier our crawler
considers many millions of pages every
day
but allows under a million into our
index at a time
documents expire from the index once
they get too old
which to us means when users stop
interacting with them and so our index
is constantly changing over
and it entirely changes over about once
a week
each document that enters our index goes
through a lot of processing
looking at this snippet from my home
feed you can actually see most of the
information that we have about each
article
each document has a publisher for this
article it's car throttle
we have hundreds of thousands of
publishers in our system
we also extract the author of each
article intuitively this seems like
useful information
since perhaps you have a preference for
a particular writer on a particular
site i know that i do
next up you see the age of the article
it turns out the date extraction is
actually quite tricky for us
some documents will have open graph date
tags and it's great when they do and we
certainly use them
but oftentimes there's no metadata to
rely on and so we have to extract the
article date ourselves and it turns out
that articles actually tend to have lots
of dates in them
there's when the article was written
when the article was updated
there's all the dates on all the
comments in the article there's the date
in the url sometimes and
sometimes just for fun i think websites
will display the current date and time
and so for a while for a while we punted
on this
and just used the date that we fetched
the article but
eventually we built an in-house date
extractor and though it's imperfect it's
still quite accurate
documents also get labeled with topics
so for this article it's cars and
automobile design
i want to go into a little bit of detail
here about our topic classifier
so our topic classifier can classify
articles into over 5000 documents
and we're actually about to do a major
expansion to extend that list by orders
of magnitude
documents can be labeled with multiple
topics and the classifier will give a
degree of confidence for them
these are the same topics that our users
can add as interests
and which help determine which articles
we show them
the topics are a critical component of
our system for many reasons
including the ability to explore new
interests which is something we want our
users to do
so when we show you the topics on an
article we don't just show you the
topics that you're subscribed to
but all the topics that we can fit into
the space provided
this becomes a way to expand out from a
current interest into new
related interests i wish i had time to
go into more detail about how we
actually built our topic classifier
but there's not time in this talk but
you can certainly ask me about it later
so let's get back to the article if you
shared your twitter or your facebook
oauth with us
then we know what articles your friends
are sharing and because we have lots of
people's oauth
we generally know what's being shared a
lot
and while we don't necessarily want to
show you everything that's been shared
by all of your twitter or facebook
friends
clearly it should be a useful indicator
for each article we also know all of the
actions performed by prismatic users who
viewed the article on prismatic
the full set is click like which we also
call recommend
save share as in share via email or
share out to facebook to share out to
twitter
and remove which is when you x out an
article that you don't like
only some of these actions are publicly
viewable by other users
but we can learn from all of them
we also pull out the title of the
article and the text
and we can look for key informative
terms these are the ones with high tf
idf if you know what that means and
these terms can help give us a
fingerprint of what a story is about
we also have information about our users
which we fully utilize
prismatic users can follow one another
and obviously we know all the people
that you follow on prismatic
and so if several of them like a story
we should be more inclined to show you
that story as well
users can also add topics and publishers
to their favorite interests
so we know what your stated interests
are
next we have recorded information about
each user
we maintain long-term summary statistics
for every topic or publisher that every
user has ever interacted with
you can view it as a summary score if
i've removed a lot of articles from
thought catalog
then thought catalog should have a
negative score if i click on a lot of
cat stories
and i do click on a lot of cat stories
then the cat's topic will have a high
positive score
obviously this information should be
useful for picking stories for a user
particularly particularly in the case
where there's an interest that a user
clicks on a lot but has not added to
their favorites
or if there's a source that a user has
removed a lot
lastly we have saved off session data we
snapshot every session that a user has
and we save off the articles that were
shown to the user and the order that
they were shown in
we also save what actions the user took
on which articles and the users state at
the beginning of the session
including what interests they have as
favorites and what their interest scores
were
one thing that's worth noting and will
come up again later
is that when we generate a feed we often
generate far more articles than the user
actually scrolls through
and so for the articles that they didn't
reach we can't know how they
hypothetically would have interacted
with them
and so we only save off session
information through the articles that
the user actually
scrolled through
so next i'm going to talk about some of
the constraints that we need to work
with it
we make each user's personalized feed on
the fly so that we can provide you with
the highest quality and most up-to-date
feed possible
this also means that the api call to get
a ranked feed
is a user-facing call and must be done
very very quickly
on the order of a couple of hundred
milliseconds
the set of documents that we will
consider showing a user is based on
their interests and their social network
and so it's not the entire document
index but it is a very large subset of
it
as i'm about to get to we do the ranking
by giving a score to each of these
documents for the current user
and then we sort by these scores given
that we need each score computation to
be lightning fast
we also have to deal with the fact that
what users claim to like
and what they actually like are often
quite different
i think users favorite interests are
often aspirational in the same way that
they are on dating websites
where everyone claims to like hiking and
cooking and reading
and no one claims to enjoy getting
stoned on their couch eating potato
chips and watching trashy reality tv
i really like these pictures um
so lastly i'm sorry to state the obvious
here
but different users are different we
hear both
my friends are idiots and i don't care
about what they share and
all i want is a form to discuss stories
with my friends
all of the time the reality is some
people want more topic-based content
some people want more social based
content and most want a mix of the two
but to varying degrees and so we have to
invisibly deal with all of these
conflicting desires
so before we get to how we actually do
it we need to answer an important
question
which is how do we even know if we've
done a good job
so the true objective is improved user
engagement
are users coming back more often are
they generally having a better
experience
but the first problem with this metric
is that it takes a long time for user
behavior to change
and it takes even longer to confidently
measure that it has changed
if our development cycle depended on
measuring user engagement
it would take weeks to evaluate a ranker
and we need to be able to iterate
much more quickly than that we also
can't do machine learning
on standard engagement metrics because
we need information about which
specific articles the user did and did
not like
so instead we need something that we can
calculate offline
from that raw session data that we saved
off that i told you about earlier
but of course we have to believe that
our metrics are a good surrogate for
user engagement so instead we ask
ourselves
are people interacting more are they
reading for longer are they removing
fewer articles
and based on the belief that more
interaction is correlated with a better
experience we came up with a set of
interaction-based metrics that we use to
evaluate a model
these metrics will give a better score
if there's more good articles so
articles the user clicks on our shares
and they're higher up in the ordered
list
and if there's fewer bad articles those
are ones the user x's out
and they're lower down in the list
we can use these metrics along with our
saved
saved session data to quickly iterate
offline by splitting this data into
training data and test data
initially we squirrel away the test data
and we don't look at what user at what
users interacted with in those test
sessions
we develop a model using only the
training data
we then take the users and the articles
in the test sessions and use and use our
newly trained ranking model
to reorder the articles hoping that the
ones the user interacted with positively
will float to the top of the ordering
and the ones that the user removed will
move to the bottom
okay so now we can get to the good stuff
and uh
i can describe to you how we actually
build our relevant system
so how do we turn this into a machine
learning problem well
we can look at people's old sessions and
though like i said earlier
we can't know anything about how they
hypothetically may have interacted with
the stories that they didn't scroll to
we can learn a lot from how they
interacted with the ones we did show
them
so to do this we build a model of
article user interactions
such that for an article user pair we
predict how positively or negatively
that user is likely to respond to that
document
our first step was to collect data this
is more than just user article
interaction triplets
we need to know the state of the world
at the time the user saw that document
what were the users favorites what were
the users per topic
and per publisher interaction scores
from previous interactions
what was the social activity on the
article at the time we had to make a
decision
all articles will start off with no
prismatic activity and so we need to
learn to identify promising stories even
if there's no activity on them
here is a visual representation where
one session log
gets transferred into many data and
where each datum includes the article
the user
and whether it was a positive or a
negative interaction
next we need to come up with a set of
features for these data
these are basically questions that we
can answer programmatically
about article user pairs
they should be based on facts which
should help you determine how likely
a user is to like or dislike a
particular article
here are some examples does the article
have any topics that the user follows
if so the future value is one otherwise
it's zero
other good features are things like the
number of times the user previously
clicked on documents from this publisher
or the number of times the user
previously removed articles from this
publisher
whether or not the article has a picture
or the number of other prismatic users
who have liked the given article
all of the content analysis that i
showed you earlier is used in these
features
authors article age topics publishers
all of that stuff gets transferred
translated into features like this
once we have the future values so these
are just the numbers
we can now represent this datum as a
vector of numbers
so now that we have these features we
want to learn weights for them
this is the learn part of machine
learning
a positive weight should indicate that
this feature means that a user is more
likely to like an article
and a negative weight should indicate
that this feature means that a user is
more likely to dislike an article
the magnitude of the weight should
indicate how big of an impact that
feature should have
we then take these feature values which
we computed from the user in the article
and the feature weights which our ranker
has learned and i'll describe more very
shortly
and we compute their dot product this
gives us a score for the user
article pair that tells us overall in
summary
how much we think the user will like or
dislike this particular article
so our goal then is to find the best
possible values for these weights
we use a model called logistic
regression for those of you who are
familiar with it
basically we want to find the weights
which cause the positive examples
that is the good articles to have large
positive scores
and which cause the negative examples
the bad articles
to have large negative scores
getting back to our visible visual
representation you can now see that each
of these data is transformed into simply
a future vector of numbers
and a positive or negative for whether
it represents a positive or negative
example
depending on the weight vector that we
use we can now compute scores for each
of these data
here's one set of possible scores you
can see that for the first and the last
data
here the scores line up properly with
whether it's a positive or negative
example
and that the two in the middle are
mismatched this means that for this
particular set of weights
our ranker would think that the user is
likely to enjoy the second article
and dislike the third article when in
reality the opposite is true
there are an infinite number of possible
weight vectors that we could choose from
and we want the one that gives the green
data the highest possible positive score
and the red ones the lowest possible
negative score
like this
so how do we actually find these weights
we use numeric optimization
do you remember when you took calculus
and you learned how to find the maximum
of a function
by taking the derivative and then
finding the point where it equals zero
well this is that but just with
thousands of dimensions one for every
feature
and so the optimization determines how
the different features get traded off
between
is a social signal worth twice as much
as having a topic in common
or is topics in common more important
instead of just
guessing we find the mathematical
optimum
so now we're on to step four classifying
new data
i need some coffee
on one level classifying new data is
trivial
a user comes to the site and we compute
a future vector for that user
and every document or every document
posts some sort of filter
and then we get scores for that article
and we sort
but there's a problem here earlier in
the talk i said that we need this call
to return
in several hundred milliseconds and if
we need to construct a new feature
vector for this many documents
a new object we're going to be hosed
before we even begin
so instead we do some algebraic
manipulation
in our original formulation the one that
we actually use when training offline
and that i've been describing to you
thus far
the weight vector is user specific but
the weights themselves are universal
however we constructed the features so
that the ones which are user specific
can actually be constructed from other
features which are only over the
document
this table on the top shows three
features the first two are about topics
on the article and have nothing to do
with whatever the current user is
the last feature is user specific but it
is closely related to those first two
features
in this case let's assume that i do have
cats as a favorite interest but i do not
have photography
so what we do in our faster formulation
on the bottom
is we remove the user specific features
and instead we manipulate the weight
vector to be user specific
in this case that means that we would
update the weight for the
article has the topic cats feature by
adding in the weight for
article has a topic that the user
favorited because the user has
cats as a favorite topic
the wait for article has topic
photography
does not get updated because i do not
have photography as a favorite
because of this transformation when new
documents enter our index
we need only compute this static feature
vector
and then all we need to do to score
documents when a user comes into the
site
is to do this one weight transformation
and then we can do a fast dot product on
all of the documents
with no expensive object creation
so the cycle that i described in the
first three steps is shown
in purple here we can train a model we
can evaluate it on our save data
and then based on the result of that
evaluation we update the model
usually by adding more features this
cycle is very fast because it operates
entirely on saved off session data
it also doesn't require us to use live
users as guinea pigs
however once we have a model whose
offline performance we are happy with
we will want to deploy it to live users
to see how it does
this is the cycle drawn in red
this cycle is much slower so we have to
spend most of our efforts on the purple
cycle
and only deploy to real users when we
feel confident with the current model
the red cycle is very very important
though because when we deploy to real
users
things often don't go as expected
which brings me to my favorite section
which is the problems and the stumbling
blocks that we encountered along
the way
so i'm going to discuss each of these
five issues that we ran into one at a
time
so when we first deployed our first
trained model to production we were
super excited
according to all of our offline metrics
this new ranker was substantially better
than what had previously been up on prod
we were ready for show time of course we
didn't want to deploy the new ranker to
100 of our users right away
so some sessions were ranked by the old
model and some by the new model so that
we could compare between the two
well our excitement quickly turned to
disappointment when the numbers started
rolling in
our new ranker was doing a lot worse
than the old one on all of our
interaction based metrics
we started investigating and we noticed
that the weight that we had learned
for a publisher match interest score so
you have an interest score for the
publisher on the document
was a lot higher than we'd expected we
figured it would have a positive weight
but a much smaller positive weight
this didn't pass our intuitive smell
test and we suspected that we probably
had a bug somewhere
since our since our code for saving off
the session data was much newer than our
core machine learning code
we looked there first and we found our
bug when we were saving off session data
if a user interacted with any articles
during the session
the updates to that user's interest
scores were happening before we snapshot
at the session
and not after like it was supposed to be
the effect of this is really really bad
what happens is this so like i said
earlier we have hundreds of thousands of
publishers
this means that a lot of articles that
we show a user will be from publishers
they have never interacted with before
and often times when a user clicks on an
article it will be the first time that
they clicked on an article from that
particular publisher
at the top here you can see what the
future value should have been in the
case of a clicked on article from a
previously unseen publisher
below that you can see what it actually
was when we were training the model
every single document that a user had
clicked on would have an interest score
for that article's publisher
and as a result the numeric optimization
process was inadvertently exploiting
this bug
and it learned a really high feature
weight
when we were evaluating offline the data
had the same bug
and so it looked to us like we were
doing really well but when we then
deployed this ranker it was placing way
too much value on the publisher
and this was causing you know poor poor
results for our users
this is pretty typical for a machine
learning bug your code doesn't crash
there's nothing blatantly wrong that you
can just go in and fix
instead the data just seems kind of off
and you have to think about it a lot and
use reason to figure out where it came
from
next up is presentation bias which is
the fact that users are
april a priori more likely to click on
earlier articles
and especially the first article
presented
search engines also suffer from this
problem
it's annoying in several ways our
learning algorithm is based on the
assumption
that when a user has a positive
interaction with a document it's because
of something inherent to that article
and not something external like that
article's location in a list
so this leads to noisier input training
data
it also makes live classifiers like
sorry live rankers
look better than they are since people
are inclined to click on earlier
articles presented
regardless of quality there's really not
a whole lot you can do about this
other than to just be aware of it
next up i want to talk about a problem
that we encountered
specifically because we were doing
ranking instead of normal machine
learning
most machine learning algorithms
including the one that we used
are based on the premise that the
training data and the test data are
drawn from the same distribution
unfortunately for us at training time we
only know about the 50 or so documents
that the user actually viewed
but when used in production we generate
thousands of ordered documents
what this means is that the 50 documents
that we are looking at are the ones that
we already had reason to think are
pretty good
because they were the 50 highest ranked
articles for that user by whatever the
previous ranker was
this means that we learn from only a
small fraction of the documents that
were presented to the user
when we had to guess what to show the
user we guess from the entire collection
of documents
and the two look very different this can
lead to pathological behavior
which i will explain with an example
that we actually experienced
and for those of you who are users you
may remember this phase because we got
a lot of complaints um so the daily mail
writes a lot of stories every day and
they get tweeted and they get shared on
facebook a lot
but it turns out that our users don't
really like the daily mail and so
the ranker that we started this whole
process with rarely served up daily mail
articles
and so for a daily mail article to end
up in a user's feed
there had to be something really special
about it it had to actually be a good
daily mail article
and so the user was more likely to click
on it but so then what happens the next
time that we train a ranker
we find that there are not that many
daily mail stories since we only train
documents from the small green circle
that when there is a daily mail article
they have a high click-through rate and
so as a consequence we learn a high
weight for the daily mail
well we deploy this new ranker with a
high daily mail weight
and now we're showing everyone daily
mail up the wazoo and so they start
removing the daily mail articles remove
remove remove
and then the next time that we train we
learn um the next time that we train the
model
we learn that the daily mail daily mail
always gets removed
and we give it a negative weight and so
now
we're right back where we started and
the cycle continues
um this is one example but really it
ended up happening for all sorts of
different features
because our training data and our test
data are inherently different
we can't totally fix this problem we
ended up alleviating it by removing
raw publisher features and other very
specific features like them
however because we still have features
based on interest scores
if a particular user clicks on the daily
mail a lot we will still learn to show
that particular user daily mail articles
so this one was fun statistical bleeding
so usually we have multiple rankers
running at the same time for comparison
one common situation where this is the
case is when we have an existing ranker
and we want to test out a new one to
potentially replace it
and when we do this we'll slowly ramp up
the fraction of users that get the new
ranker over the course of a week or two
for the sake of simplicity let's assume
that one ranker is all about exploration
represented here by the painting of
lewis and clark it's got a decent
likelihood of showing users brand new
articles out of no activity
hoping to find undiscovered gems in this
scenario the second ranker
is all about exploitation represented by
the businessman who's eavesdropping on
lewis and clark
the exploiter keeps showing users the
documents that have a lot of positive
interactions already
figuring they are good articles and
people will probably like them
you guys see where this is going
if you have 90 of users on the explore
ranker
and 10 on the exploit ranker the
explorer ranker will unearth all of the
good articles
and only then will the exploit ranker
take these documents under consideration
to show people
i've drawn an example up here to show
how the information gets passed between
the two
rankers you can see that when a new
article comes in
the exploiter won't show it to anyone
because it has no activity
but the explorer will and let's say that
this new article is a good one
and so the user clicks on it this causes
the statistics on the article to get
updated
which the exploiter also has access to
because the exploit ranker can see these
statistics it knows that it is a good
article and so it will show it to other
users
the exploit ranker will probably do
pretty good in this scenario
since it's making the explorer anchor do
all of the hard work
if the explorer anchor was the old
ranker and the exploiter was the new one
that we were considering switching over
to
the exploit one will be looking pretty
good right now and we'd be cranking up
the fraction of users who are on it
but what happens well eventually the
exploiter is the only ranker
and there is no one to do the
exploration and so the exploit ranker
will just keep showing users the same
sad couple documents
over and over again and never get any
better
based on how strongly weighted the
activity and the social features are
this is an exaggerated version of what
really happens
and so we have to be mindful to keep
retraining as we crank up the number of
users who are switched over
so the model learns over the correct
inputs
all right i saved the best one for last
how many of you know what simpson's
paradoxes
any a few so this is the wikipedia
example that i found to be most
intuitive
in the 1970s uc berkeley was sued for
bias against women who had a plot who
had applied for admission to graduate
school there
the admissions figures for fall of 1973
shown here
showed that men were except were
applying were much much more likely to
be accepted than women
and the difference was so large that it
was unlikely to be due to chance
but when examining the individual
departments
it appeared that no department was
significantly biased against women
in fact most departments had a small but
statistically significant bias
in favor of women the data from the six
largest departments are shown here
so what's the explanation
what happened was that women tended to
apply to competitive departments with
low rates of admission
even among qualified applicants whereas
men tended to apply to less competitive
departments
with high rates of admission among
qualified applicants
and so in summary it looked like the
women were being discriminated against
but in reality the different departments
did not have the same acceptance rates
and women tended to apply to the
departments that accepted fewer
applicants
the same thing happened to us we were
super confused at first
when we were looking at live results we
often break it down like this we'll be
comparing two rankers
and we'll look at both summary
information as well as how each ranker
did on each of our two platforms
iphone and web one day we were looking
at results
and we realized that ranker one did
better in summary but ranker two did
better on both of the individual
platforms
so we were super confused but my
colleague jason was the first to propose
that it might be an example of simpson's
paradox
and he was right what happened
was that we would shift the percentage
of users who got each ranker
and because users are more likely to use
the iphone at some times of day
and more likely to use the web at others
it ended up that more iphone users had
sessions with ranker one
while more web users had sessions with
ranker 2.
this combined with the fact that overall
people are more likely to click on
articles when they're on the iphone than
when they are on the web
and so because iphone users click more
and more of them got ranker 1
this corrupted the summary statistics to
make it look like ranker 1 was better
when in fact ranker 2 was better
after this we started resetting data
collection every time we changed ranker
percentages
so onto some results so
i never really explained to you what our
original ranking model looked like
before we switched to our machine
learning model
i'm not going to go into much detail
about it now but basically
some little small parts of it were
learned but mostly it was just a
hand-tuned model over a small number of
features
and so here you can see how the current
live ranker that we have up on
production right now
performed compared to the original
ranker users are sharing about 50
more um there's a 25 higher likelihood
that a user will click on the first
document
so even with presentation bias that's
still clearly a huge win
users are staying longer sessions are
about 15 percent longer
and lastly we have 15 percent fewer
total crap sessions um which means a
session where user doesn't click on
anything
share on anything do anything just kind
of scroll and peace out
and so overall we're super happy with
these results
and so here's a little summary of
everything that i've told you so far so
we collect information about our users
preferences and disk preferences
both explicit which is the favorites
that they've added and the people that
they follow
as well as implicit which is what stuff
do they actually click on
we analyze all of the articles in our
index to understand what they're about
so this is the topics and the publishers
and the key informative terms and the
date and the article
all of that and then we snapshot the
user sessions that we're actually going
to do
the direct learning on from those
sessions
we extract features which are meant to
be hints that should help us decide if a
user will like an article or not we then
learn weights for these features
which determine how the how the features
trade off between each other and how we
learn which features are more valuable
which features are less valuable
and then we use these weights to rank
articles for our user
and then lastly i want to thank the rest
of the prismatic back-end team
relevance at prismatic is not a
one-woman show the entire back end team
worked together on our relevance model
jason wolfe is here in the audience and
that strange leap you i should go try to
talk to him later and the rest of the
team is dave goland arya higgigi
and ian wong and that's it
thanks for listening and i think we got
about 10 minutes for questions